mujeres lanzando sus velos al aire y
cortándose el cabello en público esta
imagen se ha convertido en el símbolo de
las protestas contra la autoridad en
Irán en otro lugar en la ciudad
occidental de majabat una multitud grita
muerte al dictador mientras un incendio
arde en la oficina del gobernador local
Mientras tanto en la capital Teherán un
mes y medio después de la muerte de
maxaminey varios cientos de personas
corean consignas contra la República
islámica las protestas en todo Irán
están lejos de disminuir y también la
represión que en todo caso se está
haciendo más fuerte según amnistía
internacional las fuerzas de seguridad
han matado al menos a ocho manifestantes
Desde el miércoles una reacción de mano
dura que ha provocado una rápida
respuesta de la comunidad internacional
Francia anunciado nuevas sanciones
mientras que Naciones Unidas ha dicho
que ha iniciado investigaciones
independientes
la comunidad internacional tiene
responsabilidad de tomar medidas para
abordar la impunidad por violaciones de
los Derechos Humanos en Irán y por lo
tanto he pedido el rápido
establecimiento de un mecanismo de
investigación independiente en todas las
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos que
condujeron a la muerte de Gina y desde
entonces maxamí los manifestantes han
sido detenidos en masa en la represión
de lo que el presidente de Irán Ibrahim
raíz y considera como disturbios
Mientras tanto se inició una
investigación sobre terrorismo luego de
un ataque que mató al menos a 15
personas en un santuario chiquito en la
ciudad de shiraz el miércoles